tyrese you guys know him from fast and
furious and many other
hit films so he posted his picture in a
masjid
this image is of the first time i ever
stepped
foot in a mosque been praying that one
day we'd have this conversation have
some muslims drinking alcohol
you have some muslims doing things that
they shouldn't be doing opposite to
islam
muslims nobody's perfect but religion
like islam is perfect
this is what i did i opened up a world
religious book i watched some debates
and i was looking at what do these
what's the main message of these
religions multiple numbers
god's not a human being a man
which is a greeting of peace thank you
for tuning in to the dean show tyreese
you guys know him from fast and furious
and many other
hit films he's a famous celebrity
and he is seeking some advice
he we're gonna go ahead and comment on
a message that he put out there so let's
go ahead and get into this message
and hopefully we could be of some small
assistance so he posted his picture in a
masjid
and he said this image is of the first
time i ever
stepped foot in a mosque we went alone
so that i could embrace the entire
religious process
and i left there so inspired i learned
so much
same thing happened when i went to
israel and prayed at the wailing wall
born and raised in a christian household
with strong faith in my belief system
after going to the middle east 10 times
i found myself
struggling at times with my faith please
let's be mature he says here in the
comments and have an open dialogue
here's the first question he says number
one tyrese is asking
have you ever been in a place where you
considered
switching your faith and belief system
two
if you ever change your religious
beliefs
did you go from christian to muslim
muslim to christian christian to what
he's asking
then then tyrese goes on to say please
explain
i am always asking questions hoping
someone has answers
keep in my mind
this is not about religious warfare so
keep it clean and respectful please
and men and women of faith this is a
powerful teachable moment
so please be very alive in the comments
i want to start off with the beginning
where therese is talking about visiting
a mosque
you have so many people scared of
muslims nowadays because of the media
because of the hype that's one thing
that we can take from this
he did something noble he went and
stepped in
to a house of god a house of worship so
go visit the muslims visit a mosque like
he did
number two he was so inspired after
visiting the mosque
he also learned so much education is key
so my advice from this look his mind is
open and for the mind like a wise man
said
for the mind to function properly and
needs to be open like a parachute
so keep the mind open like he did and
don't let nobody
fool you and think for you go in for
yourself
and see what the muslims believe meet
with the muslims
make the connection with muslims and
again muslim is simply one who
submits his or her will to the will of
the creator of the heavens and earth the
other point he mentions is he's been
struggling with his faith
now let's be honest here there are many
people who
look i've been doing this program for a
long time since 2006
and i've interviewed hundreds of people
and and so many tyrese
i've encountered so many people with the
similar struggle that you went through
so they were born in a christian
household and anytime i know this is
sensitive to a lot of people so
i don't want to disparage on anybody's
faith or anything and just this is with
kindness in a
in a nice benign way that i'm just
trying to illustrate the same struggles
that other people went through
that the trinity you know this belief
system that god is three in one
people struggle with that and you can't
just blame
somebody somebody for coming out and
expressing that they don't understand it
and
it and it really impacts their heart and
soul they can't submit to something that
they just fully can't understand
now you can't fully understand the
creator of heaven's earth but the
concept
the basic simple belief system you have
to be able to understand it has to be
lucid and clear
number two people struggle with this god
man concept god being god but a man at
the same time
you know it just goes against common
sense and logic
and people struggle with that also god
coming down
walking the earth and then dying you
know this crucifixion
and then when they look into islam and
they go from all around i mean i've seen
this happen
countless times where people go all
around the world and check every
religion i did the same thing i opened a
really
i i opened up and i recommend tyree says
you do that just a simple
a simple world religions book and you
look at everything you don't have to go
deep into it and you see in one way or
another
a the creation worship this is what i
did i opened up a world religious book
i watched some debates and i was looking
at
what do these what's the main message of
these religions and i saw that the
majority of all of them
were in one way or another calling the
human being to worship the
creation but then islam stood out why
and with everybody that i interviewed
finally they came to islam because all
the negative hype and propaganda
kept them away from islam but then they
were still searching so then they came
to islam against islam simply means to
acquire peace you want peace contentment
purpose in life you submit your will to
the creator of life the creator of the
human being that's what islam is to
to acquire peace by submitting yourself
you do what god wants you to do on his
terms not your desires
so now that's islam and then what
happened from there they saw as
i saw the simple lucid message that was
so simple
it resonated with the heart of the pure
monotheism
that you only worship one and only one
god
you don't add three two multiple numbers
god's not a human being a
you know you've man visiting the muslim
country predominantly muslim countries
and again don't take the muslims
as examples because you'll have some
muslims drinking alcohol you have some
muslims doing things that they shouldn't
be doing opposite to islam
muslims nobody's perfect but religion
like islam is perfect
islam is perfect so we go to the perfect
example of islam
that's muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him he's the last and final
mentioner sent to mankind
so now when you look at these
certain points that he mentions he talks
about did you go from christian to
muslim
also he's always asking questions keep
asking the questions
read the quran read the quran and keep
asking questions keep
having an open heart mind but the number
one thing i want you to do is
keep that connection direct with your
creator
and ask the creator alone to guide you
sincerely let tears come out
people are going to attack you people
are going to because you have a strong
platform
you can make a lot of good happen from
you accepting islam
you know the enemy forces the shia team
you know they're going to come and
they're going to attack you know people
through human beings and the unseen
spirits they're going to come and
they're going to try to
hinder that way so but if you're
resolute and you're firm
and you're connected to your creator one
and only you just pray directly to him
and you ask him guide me guide me guide
me he will facilitate away
and then in in short in closing connect
we see her in the comments you see
real loon to amir this is our brother
our brother loon who also accepted islam
connect with him loon says been praying
that one day we'd have this conversation
dm me when you get a chance inshallah i
highly recommend you hook up with our
brother loon
and he can also he went through the
whole process and i'll leave you with a
couple more things before we conclude
one there's only as we said one and only
one god
he sent messengers throughout time and
these messengers came
with the same message worship one and
only one god some people obeyed
many people went astray they followed
their lust passions desires and all
these other man-made religions started
to come
afloat and then god will send other
messengers and some of those messengers
we know throughout time some of the
great that are mentioned in the quran
you've got noah moses
abraham who are jesus peace be upon him
one of the mightiest messengers ever
sent to mankind and prophet
muhammed just being the seal of the
prophets the last and final messenger
sent to mankind
and then they came with miracles and
signs
and during jesus time he did certain
miracles
to prove that he was indeed a messenger
not god
son of literal son of god same thing
with moses moses time but those
that was at their time you had to follow
them obey
them and worship the way they worship
and they didn't worship themselves
they didn't worship human beings they
didn't worship saints idols
themselves as god no their ideas as god
you got to sometimes
break the first idol that's yourself
people have egos and now they start to
make up their own i'm just spiritual i'm
not religious and they make their own
religion it doesn't make sense
we're here we're put on this earth for a
purpose the one who created purpose the
one who created us
that's the one the one and only creator
that heavens and earth that's the one
that we got to follow we got to obey
and now the ultimate miracle that we
have today
living is the quran so we went from one
god sending messenger and that guidance
that we have today for all of mankind
read the quran i really wanted to keep
this short but i get excited talking
about this so i'll just try to keep it
condensed you know just get
your feet a little bit wet and give you
some give you a little bit of taste why
do we say the quran is
from the creator from god almighty
because in the quran it says god
almighty is saying
that this book is from the creator of
the heavens and earth prophet muhammad
couldn't read or write so on every page
of the quran god's name is mentioned in
there
and god almighty is saying that he's
going to preserve this book that's a
prophecy and has been preserved
until this day it's authentic we know
who it's coming from
there is a science behind it if you
investigate and you look
you'll see that there's no way that this
book could come from anyone other than
the creator of the heavens and earth
number two a very important point the
quran challenges the human being
if you think this is from other than the
creator of the heavens and earth produce
something like it
come come come there's a falsification
test in the quran number three
this is really risky there are
prophecies in the quran yes
prophecies for somebody to say for
example just for example hey the earth
is going to end
human life is going to come to an end
and 2012
and that passes this would discredit
because if some if prophet muhammad
peace be upon him the quran mentions
something
and then it doesn't come to fruition and
the time has passed
this cancels out everything you don't
see that happening with the quran there
are over 500 scientific facts in the
quran the develop just to
mention a few the creation of the
universe how the universe began it's
mentioned the quran
the development of the human being from
the early stages of the embryo it's
mentioned in the quran
as far as it is known from the history
of embryology
little was known about the staging and
classification
of human embryos until the 20th century
for this reason the descriptions of the
human embryo in the quran
cannot be based on scientific knowledge
in the seventh
seventh century the only reasonable
conclusion
is that these descriptions were revealed
to muhammad from god
he could not have known such details
because he was an illiterate man
with absolute absolutely no scientific
training
last point there are many many more but
again i'm just giving you a taste test
the quran last and final one look it
tells us
do they not consider the quran with care
had it been from other than your creator
from allah you would find in
many discrepancies contradictions go
ahead and find one i'm not talking about
from these people from the
the hate machine the provocateurs people
who are you know twisting
you know confusing people putting false
fiction out there now i'm talking about
if you're genuine sincere
you go sit with somebody a learned
person a scholar look for yourself
you will see that there's no way that
muhammad
was somebody who could have written the
quran
a group of men could not have written
the quran a whole nation could not have
written the quran the devil didn't write
the quran but the creator of the heavens
and earth
sent the quran for you tyrese for all of
mankind
so with that said one more thing look to
your roots
and if you go to your roots to african
americans tyrese you will see
that it links back to islam the muslim
american hero who did that
many of them did that but the one that's
remembered in this country
the muslim american hero muhammad ali he
went back to his roots he found islam
malcolm x he went back to his roots he
found islam submission to the creator
not the creation
and then if you go further back kunta
kinte he was saying allah the creator is
the creator
worship being the one the p on the pure
monotheism
i'm very elated to see someone like you
who is really searching
you know keep those qualities of
sincerity being genuine in your search
and be
connected and you got to be brave ask
god almighty allah
to strengthen you because you will have
opposition
to this truth you will have family
coming after you you so you need a
support mechanism and the best support
is your creator is the creator god
almighty allah hook up with flu don't
forget
and we're here also to help if you need
us hook up with us tyrese we'd love to
connect with you maybe in the future
have you on the program until next time
peace be with you assalamu alaikum